our next guest actress joey king is
quickly becoming a household name across
america she starred in the netflix
trilogy the kissing booth which was a
hit she was nominated for an emmy in a
golden globe for a portrayal of gypsy
rose blanchard in the crime series the
act in 2020 check this out king was
named on the forbes 30 under 30 list at
just 20 years old now she plays tessa in
the film the in-between for our
streaming service paramount plus it's a
supernatural love story about a high
school girl who falls in love with a
teenage boy named skylar after he dies
in an accident tessa believes he's
trying to reconnect with her from the
after world in this clip tessa tells her
stepmom about her feelings for skylar
you love skylar don't you
i think i'm screwing it up
yeah
if it's not opening old wounds it's
probably not true love
i just don't know what to do
how do i get skyler to understand that
i love him
you start by saying it
joining us right now is joey king
rocking that green girl i see you thank
you and you said such nice things in my
intro thank you so much and joey they're
all true yeah they're awesome you
deserve it i want to get to the
character though you describe your
character tessa as someone who's
hardened with trauma um what drew you to
this script to this to this character
what really drew me to this the script
in this character is yes i think tessa's
hardened by family trauma and it's just
like she's very closed off when we meet
her to the idea of finding love or
in in a relationship or familial like
you know she doesn't have a great
relationship with her family
um but what really drew me to this story
was
how
i it was so beautifully written touching
on such dark subject matter um but
somehow it just makes you feel all like
oh gushy inside and also has like a
really beautiful message within it as
well i know it's a very sweet story
because i was only going to watch 10
minutes just to get a sense of it and
then i was totally sucked in joey but
you know the other thing i like are the
dual timelines because it goes back and
forth between between the two characters
and it's a movie most people are very
uncomfortable even talking about death
much less doing a movie about it but you
said making this movie helped you
overcome your fear of death what what
did you mean by that i feel like it kind
of just
helps
view death in like a different light
like death is very scary it's hard to
talk about it's also especially hard to
talk about with younger people and i
feel like this movie geared towards
younger audiences i feel for me anyway
it just kind of helped me
put a different perspective on death and
that it doesn't always have to be a
a horrible like scary thing it can
you can rework the way you feel about it
to like live a little bit more
peacefully with it and it was a lot of
fun making this you had a post on
instagram actually about how uh it's
hard to describe how much fun it was
could you try for it
it was like because you're shooting in
covent yeah well weirdly for being a
movie that was shot in covet and it's
like so sad
um we had so much fun me and the lead of
the movie cody the movie kyle allen uh
we became such great friends and we just
had so much fun filming together we just
we were just had the best time celeste
o'connor who played my best friend was
also so great um so we just it was great
it was really really wonderful and we
would be like joking around and then
like the next minute be like oh no
you're dying but like joey i love that
as you sit here with us at 22 number one
guys check out our shoes oh yeah oh my
god here at the age of 22 you have your
own production company you're a producer
in the movie how did you decide at this
stage in your life you wanted your own
production company listen you've been
around for a while you've had a very
long acting career and not wait
sometimes they say in hollywood you got
to earn your strides right you're like
you know what my time is now right i
mean i've been doing this for a really
long time i'm on in business yeah pretty
crazy to say i've been doing this for 18
years um which the math checks out like
i know it sounds crazy
but um i feel like i've grown up in this
industry i love this industry i want to
learn everything i possibly can about it
so getting into this role of producing i
feel like allows me to really see what
goes into building a project from the
ground up and it's a lot more
complicated and a lot crazier than i
could have really ever imagined
but i have such a love for how it's made
and how much work goes into it it really
it makes you even more proud when you do
a project to know all that went into it
and your production company is called
all the king's horses yeah they're all
the kings so not all the people all the
king's forces so what type of projects
are you galloping towards uh in the
future oh dear that was quite the pun
that's what i do that's what they hired
me for that's all i do he's very good at
that
i live for a good pun
um i well the in-between was one of my
my first projects to develop but
honestly the
the way i describe what i'm looking for
i don't have like a specific desire or
genre that i'm like really going after i
don't have like a map out of my career
and how i want it to go
i really feel what i read if it makes me
happy if it's something that i feel
connected to and i want to do it whether
it seems like the right next move or
like whatever it doesn't matter to me if
i like it i want to do it and that's
what i love about being able to produce
it's like now i get to have opinions on
how to make a film even more my own and
you express those opinions and i feel
like really comfortable now expressing
those approaches and joey king is your
name on your birth certificate tony and
i both said no what's your real name i
know both of you were like is it
josephine i was like no it's just joey i
didn't want to make any assumptions i'm
a big fan of holistic names i love it
you might not have a map out of what
projects you want to do in the future
but you're laying down the blueprint for
a lot of young men and women in this
industry so congratulations that's very
kind
joy king thank you so much the
in-between is available to stream this
friday february 11th exclusively on our
streaming service paramount plus